[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
desde mediados de enero cientos de
personas retomaron las rutas migratorias
que cruzan centroamérica con el fin de
llegar a eeuu un flujo que avanza hasta
la frontera sur mexicana allí los
migrantes se encuentran con bloqueos y
demoras en sus trámites en tapachula se
concentran miles de personas que esperan
permisos de movilidad el cansancio llevó
a los migrantes a iniciar una huelga de
hambre como mecanismo de presión ante
las autoridades las protestas ya son
comunes en la ciudad mexicana veamos
cuál es la situación en el informe de
andré amaya
bloqueados en el sur de méxico cientos
de migrantes protestaron en las calles
de tapachula contra redadas de las
autoridades que los han llevado hasta
centros de refugio temporales algunos
denuncian que los papeles para demostrar
su estatus como solicitantes de asilo
han sido destruidos donde estuvieron
aquí en el parque de tapachula les
enseñamos que tenemos proceso en tomar
el papel original que te da en comer
conseguir todos nos detuvieron y decían
que eso no valía que eso era falso
vinieron y lo rompieron entonces nos
llevaron presos pasamos casi 21 días
adentro en el siglo 21 y solo nos dieron
este papel que tenemos 15 días para
abandonar el país la larga espera los
llevó a comenzar una huelga de hambre
frente a las oficinas del instituto
nacional de inmigración de méxico es la
situación en tapachula se repite desde
el inicio del año cientos de migrantes
se han tomado las calles exigiendo que
las autoridades les permitan el libre
tránsito para poder ir a eeuu
los migrantes en su mayoría provenientes
de centroamérica continúan saliendo en
largas caravanas este grupo de
hondureños empezó a caminar desde
mediados de enero atravesarán guatemala
en dirección a eeuu
peligro siempre hay vaya con coyote o
vaya en caravana por qué
[Música]
siempre hay maldad en cualquier forma
con quien sea
posibilidad de pasar un imagino que si
hay un 80 por ciento 80 que pueda
existir va pero nadie les asegura que
logren su objetivo es el caso de josé
luís un migrante nicaragüense que desde
2019 espera respuesta del gobierno
estadounidense me hicieron la
la entrada a eeuu
pero a menudo me hizo a mí la
propuesta de que como yo ya tenía
familia aquí en ciudad juárez que me
esperara tres semanas para una respuesta
y pues yo me quedé esperando siete ocho
nueve meses y nunca menos respuesta como
el miles de emigrantes siguen en el lado
mexicano de la frontera con eeuu
luego de ser deportados bajo el programa
quédate en mexico que los obliga a
esperar respuesta a sus solicitudes en
ese país un programa del gobierno trump
que el presidente joe biden ha intentado
echar para atrás sin éxito
la realidad de los que permanecen
parados en méjico contrasta con el
testimonio de familias que decidieron
quedarse en el país y rehacer su vida
aunque eeuu es el destino para la
mayoría llegar al norte es un camino
largo y difícil de recorrer estamos
construyendo una vida y un futuro más
más que todo por los niños hace cuatro
años la vida de dania de diego y de sus
dos hijos volvió a empezar en mexico
huyeron de su honduras natal escapando
de la violencia de las maras que
llegaron a abrir fuego contra la casa
familiar una bala se clavó en el muslo
del pequeño en el momento que entramos
con el niño a al hospital le sacan a
bala y en el mismo instante yo veo que
los carros están entrando así
desangrando el niño todo me lo tuve que
sacar porque la intención de los mareros
era matarlos a toda la familia nunca me
imaginé abandonar mi casa porque no
éramos millonarios pero teníamos una
vida bonita
vivíamos tranquilos
instalados en el norte de mexico la
familia espera conseguir la nacionalidad
en su país de acogida
[Música]
l
yo puedo medir un vídeo objetivo y el de
familias naturalizando llegar a ese
punto de gente muy feliz
maravilloso como ellos 500 refugiados
están pendientes de que se resuelvan sus
peticiones de ciudadanía mexicana según
los datos de acnur la agencia de
naciones unidas para los refugiados ha
lanzado un plan para acompañar a los
demandantes de asilo desde la primera
solicitud hasta que están integrados en
las comunidades de acogida una meta que
danny está convencida de alcanzar para
que la violencia sea un recuerdo que sus
hijos dejen atrás el día de mañana o más
salir como un orgullo yo sé que el de
mañana ayer me va a ir mami me dijo de
lo que los pasó allá los hemos superado
y que el día de mañana yo lo voy a deber
a él con su familia aquí con el objetivo
de blindar el proceso de estabilización
de los demandantes de asilo alrededor
del mundo y que el caso de dan ya no sea
una excepción
acnur pretende que para 2024 toda la
organización funcione con los planes de
acompañamiento de larga duración
en 2021 la comisión mexicana de ayuda a
refugiados comar recibió una cifra
récord de 131 mil 448 solicitudes de
refugio y muchos siguen represados la
comisión nacional de derechos humanos le
pidió al gobierno a atender la situación
que es crítica en el sureste del país y
el dato de migración de la semana
capitán es desatar y es un documental
que retrata la historia de dos
refugiados sirios que sueñan con
convertirse en futbolistas profesionales
el filme ya fue proyectado en el
campamento que sirvió de inspiración
para el rodaje y que alberga a unos
80.000 refugiados
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]